was sagen sie zu den ins bestellung an
der eu ja grundsätzlich muss man sagen
ich habe mich ja schon geäußert dass es
eine vollkatastrophe ist und die
schulnoten betrachtet eigentlich eine 6
das hat damit zu tun wenn sie bwl
studieren in den ersten semestern werden
sie mit der aussage konfrontiert und das
haben sie dann auch zu lernen das
beschaffung so definiert ist das
richtige produkt in an den richtigen ort
in der benötigten menge zum richtigen
zeitpunkt zu einem respektablen preis
zur verfügung zu stellen und ich glaube
wenn man den vorbericht sieht die
kommentierung von dem tiger hört da kann
man nur sagen dass das vollumfänglich zu
einer schulnote von einer sechs führen
würde
was ist die ausgangssituation und das
ist das was ich jetzt im widerspruch zu
einem lauterbach sehr der sagt dass wir
müssen jetzt alle nach vorne schauen ich
verstehe dass dass die politik uns von
der richtung her in der betrachtung nach
vorne orientieren will
ich würde trotzdem gerne haben wir das
management beurteilt wissen was zu
dieser prozess geführt hat dass man
einen immer längeren lockdown und immer
weiteren lebens einschränkungen sprechen
und da gibt es verantwortlichkeiten
das ist das problem ich erlaube mir dass
meine der form herbeizuführen
für die politik ist ein monopol nicht
vorhanden wir haben auf der einen seite
den polen pohl kommission die beraten
die politik in die richtung führt dass
keine entstehen und wir haben auf der
anderen seite das kartellamt was
verhindert dass marktbeherrschende
stellung entstehen
was war jetzt das problem und zwar
intellektuell man hat nicht verstanden
dass er in dem moment wo ein hersteller
die erste zulassung erhält er ein
monopolist ist
und wenn sie im juni die verhandlungen
mit vier hersteller die sich in einem
wettbewerb befinden wer als erster über
die grenze geht
verhandeln sie mit vier gefühlten
monopolisten weil keiner dieser
hersteller hingeht und sagt klemmer dann
probleme mit meinem wettbewerber aber er
wird die erste zulassung bekommen
sondern alle vier fühlten sich in einer
monopolstruktur
was ist jetzt in der beschaffung anders
ob ich mit einem monopolisten verhandeln
oder ob ich mit einem funktionierenden
markt verhandelt wo ich eine
ausschreibung machen kann
abteilung ausschreibung europäischen
national das modell kennt jeder der sich
mit der frage der öffentlichen
beschaffung mal beschäftigt hat
bei einem monopolisten geht es nicht um
die frage des preises sondern bei einem
monopolisten monopolisten sind zwei
faktoren entscheiden zeit
und auf der anderen seite
verfügbarkeit verschiedener hat
eigentlich mein beispiel vorweggenommen
was ich heute meine tochter studieren
erzählt habe
man muss sich auch vorstellen dass diese
produzenten einen ganz bestimmten
produktionsprozess planen und daraufhin
der woche 5 1 alten herrschte
und wenn ein staat zwei einheiten
benötigt und er unterschreibt einen
vertrag im juni dann sind die ersten
zwei einheiten dieser ersten woche von 5
für ihn
und so baut sich eine lieferkette mit
versprechen auf die am ende des tages
dazu führt dass wenn die eu kommission
am zwölften november erst in biotech auf
buy
rechtlich fundiert für biotech als
auftrag akzeptabel beschließt dann sind
alle verträge die vorher abgeschlossen
wurden in einer priorisierung
abzuarbeiten
und das ist eigentlich ein konsequenter
technischer fehler der zu dieser
verzögerten liefert uns heute führt der
zweite pumpe nicht die noch ausführen
darf ist die frage der
vertragsgestaltungen ich finde es
sensationell dass wir jetzt darüber
sprechen dass produktionsschwierigkeiten
entstehen großbritannien vollumfänglich
beliefert wird und bei der eu es
eigentlich jetzt zu einer entsprechenden
lücke wird weil in diesen verträgen
gestalte ich wohl wissend es ist ein
neuer produktionsprozess habe ich
antizipiert das in einem neuen
produktionsprozess nach vorne hin
produktionsschwierigkeiten entstehen und
ich beauftrage eine neutrale stelle
diesen prozentsatz dieses
produktionsrückgangs dank zu erheben um
am ende total diese 27%
produktionsausfall in altverträgen
gleichmäßig wiederzufinden und jetzt
reden wir darüber dass sich dieser
hersteller arroganz verhält er verhält
sich marktwirtschaft ist seit man das
grundproblem ist aber ist das nicht das
grundproblem dass wir auf der einen
seite eine kommission haben die ja
ohnehin nicht den besten ruf genieße und
als sehr bürokratisch gilt und dann hat
man da so quicklebendige manager und
weltkonzerne mit jemandem verhandeln
muss und was sagen sie denn dazu dass in
den verträgen und astrazeneca steht best
effort erklären sie uns als vertrags und
verhandlungsexperte mal was bedeutet
wenn in einem vertrag steht best erfolg
also ich würde mal sagen ich hätte keine
keine existenzberechtigung mehr als
berater wenn wir derartige verträge die
wir dann dementsprechend verhandelt
hätten meinem vorstand oder dem
verantwortlichen vorstand zur
unterschrift gereichen würden best
effort ist ein vertrag den man
eigentlich in einem see
artig epochalen beschaffungsprozess jan
0,0 akzeptieren kann
ich sage bewusst epochaler
beschaffungsprozess war der bedeutendste
beschaffungsprozess den die politik seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg zu organisieren
hatte weil es geht um wirtschaftliche
auswählen aufwendungen immenser größe
nehmen sie die verschuldungsquoten
nehmen sind das mit demoskopie ich
kriege angst für meine kinder wie das
jemals bezahlt werden soll und auf der
anderen seite haben wir die ethische
größe das g weniger lockdown themen wir
haben je mehr wir eine durchimpfung der
republik hätten wir desto weniger tote
hätten
und ich meine was würden wir machen
gehören ich sagen best effort wir hätten
gesagt okay
mit ekici für die lieferung im dezember
gewähren wir dir einen aufschlag von 100
prozent auf beiden preis und für die
lieferung im januar gewähren während die
einen aufschlag von 50 prozent und ab
februar zahlen wird den normalen preis
weil 1 ist ja klar bei in einem
marktwirtschaft orientierten unternehmen
mit einem produktionsausfall liefer
haben sie sowieso ein deckungsbeitrags
verlust und diesem diese 70 oder 80
prozent der menge dienst du dank denen
die den höheren preis bezahlen
während du dann natürlich dennoch
gelungen ist einen best effort vertrag
abzuschließen dann sagst du zur
kontrolle also ich sage mal am ende des
tages sie haben das mit arroganz
bezeichnet ich verstehe das
journalistisch als mitglied in einem
wirtschaftlichen prozess betrachte ich
das nicht als arrogant sondern es ist
einfach ein spiel das miteinander in
einem kräfteverhältnis des monopolisten
und eines bedarfs an gebers ein
ungleichgewicht in der qualität der
verhandlungen entstanden ist und das was
dann beidseitig unterschrieben wurde ist
das worauf sich jetzt das recht das
jeden einzelnen bezieht
die anzeige gesagt sechs sätzen an die
verhandlungsführer mal ganz ganz in der
freien wirtschaft wen muss die eu oder
wer muss in europa eigentlich für diesen
kunden model für diesen mist und zwar
deutlich zu sagen gefeiert werden also
ich möchte mich da nicht äußern wer
gefeuert wird ich glaube nur auf der
einen seite beklagt die politik
politikverdrossenheit der bevölkerung
und das war mit ein grund warum ich mich
zu diesem thema überhaupt in dieser
woche mal geäußert habe mich ärgert
eigentlich faktisch die tatsache dass
wir unter neutralen gesichtspunkten da
können sie jeden beschaffungs experten
fragen alle meine kollegen der
beschaffungsprozess ist extrem
ungenügend durchgeführt worden
und trotzdem gibt es keine politische
konsequenz sondern die politik
entschuldigt sich gegenseitig als auch
frau merkel hat gesagt sie mag es nicht
weiter dass an herrn spahn herumgemäkelt
wird herr laschet sagte herr spahn hat
doch wirklich ein ganz tollen job
gemacht ich glaube einfach wenn man das
ergebnis sieht ich will mich gar nicht
auf namen kaprizieren dann ist das
ergebnis ungenügend und es ist eine
gefährdung der republik in
wirtschaftliche dimension als auch in
gesundheitlicher dimension
und wenn das gleiche in der wirtschaft
passiert dann ist die politik mit den
forderungen dass ein entsprechender
vorstand zurückzutreten hat oder
anderswo wenn er zurückgetreten ist dass
man sagt das ist die einzig logische
konsequenz nehmen sie in den vw skandal
da hat das jedoch von herrn winterkorn
geht vorlauf wo bis heute gar nicht klar
ist ob er von dieser software
entwicklung wusste oder gar sie zu
verantworten hatten weil er sie
beauftragt hat aber man fordert dass und
in der politik ist diese forderung nicht
mehr opportun
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren